hinter diesen türen in der berliner
charité werden die unterschiede zwischen
den geschlechtern erforscht männer gehen
anders mit ihrer gesundheit und mit
krankheiten um als frauen
heute diskutiert das team ergebnisse
einer neuen untersuchung sie zeigt
unterschiede im gesundheitsverhalten
gibt es sogar jetzt in zeiten des neuen
corona virus sich freiwillig an
schutzmaßnahmen halten wobei für männer
leichter ist die schutzmaßnahmen
umzusetzen wenn sie wenn sie
verpflichtend sind
das heißt da gibt's wieder
geschlechterunterschiede turu stadler
leitet das forscherteam
sie ist professorin für gender sensible
präventionsforschung sie interessiert
vor allem wie männer und frauen
alterserkrankungen wie übergewicht und
diabetes vorbeugen und wie ärzte sie am
besten dabei unterstützen können
da geht es immer darum dass man dass
leute sich in also gesund ernähren sich
mehr bewegen weniger genussmittel zu
sich nehmen und dann sozusagen auch dann
lange sehr gesundes leben und er
möglichst lange lebenserwartung mit
hoher lebensqualität zu erreichen
dabei gibt es große
geschlechtsspezifische unterschiede
frauen ernähren sich zum beispiel
gesünder und wissen auch viel mehr
darüber
männer kennen sich bei der bewegung
besser aus und treiben meistens auch
mehr sport
wissen dass man für hilfsangebote nutzen
kann zum beispiel beim abnehmen
frauen kommen echt ganz gut mit diesen
gruppen angeboten zu recht
kommerzielle anbieter auch zur verfügung
stellen während männer darauf probleme
haben also die hürden nehmen digitale
angebote er war auch er männergruppen
aber es heißt doch mal das zuschneidet
auf die bedürfnisse von männern und
frauen
dann hat man hoffentlich besseren erfolg
kann die leute auch in den internet für
die maßnahme besser interessieren und
dann hoffentlich langfristig mehr erfolg
ein anderes thema ist der umgang mit
schweren erkrankungen wie krebs vor und
sprechen darüber oft mit ihren
freundinnen männer suchen dagegen rat
bei ihrer ehefrau und bei ihrem arzt
männer fragen wenn sie erkrankt sind
auch danach wie sie ihren lebensstil
ändern können was sie für sich selber
tun können und dass gerade bei den
männern oft so was wie ich würde das
nennen window of opportunity also wenn
jetzt darauf eingehen und dann
entsprechend empfehlungen geben oder das
diskutieren mit den männern ist das oft
wirklich eine große chance
zb nach der diagnose prostatakrebs alles
mögliche zu verändern sich gesünder zu
ernähren sich mehr zu bewegen
stress abzubauen ein weiteres beispiel
unerfüllter kinderwunsch
während man sehr viel darüber weiß wie
frauen zum beispiel durch
gewichtsabnahme ihre fruchtbarkeit
verbessern können ist diese frage bei
männern so gut wie noch gar nicht
erforscht fokus auf die forschung an
frauen wirklich beiden frauen und
männern schadet also wohl also weil wir
dann wirklich jetzt eigentlich
suboptimale forschungs erkennen also zu
wenig wissen wie man bei männern
fruchtbarkeit fördern kann
und da wollen wir beitragen bis zu
verbessern als in dem wir wirklich beide
partner untersuchen also männer und
frauen die erforschung der geschlechter
eigenschaften ist aber nur ein anfang
denn von frau zu frau und von mann zu
mann gibt es im gesundheitsverhalten
große unterschiede
jeder mensch ist einzigartig ziel ist
daher eine medizin die auf jede person
individuell genau zugeschnitten ist
diese dichotomie mann/frau nutzen um
immer noch genauer zu verstehen die sich
patienten und patientinnen unterscheiden
also nicht nur männer und frauen
unterscheiden sondern eben auch
innerhalb der gruppen die menschen
unterscheiden in ihren
bewältigungsstrategien in ihrem
gesundheitsverhalten in dem was sie
eigentlich brauchen um ihre krankheit
gut bewältigen zu können
die genderforschung ist also nur ein
erster schritt auf dem weg zu einer
maßgeschneiderten medizin für jeden
einzelfall